hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play so to grab something let's
play the things in the night my name is
Mark blarin we're about to go into room
6
no we're not now we are haha good one
well done yeah something tells me I
don't want to close that door oh oh oh
my oh ah room 3 lordalu oh why I just
have to ask why what why is this like
this why is that
the way that it is Oh room 3 is right
across the hall
ah much better much more inviting some
mouldy bread some dead pig I guess you
wouldn't eat live Pig would you you big
freak okay some book picture of
Alexander again nothing uh-huh
absolutely dick doodly oh oh no oh it's
moose man
sup buddy
[Music]
don't knock down the door that's such a
nice door yep knocking on the door well
why didn't he get read why is it getting
read I read there why is it suddenly
read you didn't see that door move
Luke's man is so much worse than the
other guy I swear everything about him
this sound the way he moves
sounds especially but he moves that
creaking and he one-hit kills you cannot
let him get ya
did he leave think you left all right
buddy you just patrol those hallways
good job there okay I got an iron bar
rod of iron from the cell bars okay so
hey buddy so I'm assuming that there's
another door that I can why is he still
there
okay.you doesn't seem to be going away
alright anyway I got an iron bar so I'm
assuming that there's a door around here
that I can oh [ __ ] you oh I'll screw
that hard okay oh no this is the thing
that needs oil that's right okay
Oh God now there's two of them just
roaming cuz I thought I heard the creaky
crank of moose man walking around okay
there's got to be a door here or
something that needs an iron bar oh
hello
oil oh what's that hello okay yeah I
find all the secrets I'm just popping
out my lantern when I think there might
be a door nearby okay I've been to eight
six three some other ones
let me just try the rod nope okay okay
it's okay get that in here because the
monster yeah
laughs look so the monsters been in
there and nothing there for me here's
the entrance I think the entrance is
right here okay yeah right here so serve
my oil I'm finally starting to get some
oil I cannot waste it okay I've already
been in this one the doors bashed down
oh there's probably some doors in the
center hallways try this one yeah
perfect hey hello babies how you doing
how you doing oh you must have been so
lonely without me I know I know baby I
know
ah this looks important here click noise
from the knife what the knife knife
knife
oh that's go for me the knife oh the
knife here
Oh
so you were able to make it this far do
you think you could stop me now boy
father even if it's the last thing I do
I will kill you for what you've done how
could you kill your own ism
how could you kill your own wife and son
my brother like that did you even ever
love them I'll show you them mutt fights
what I'll show you my some of my love
son hey stop that hey you stop that ah
damn you father I won't let you kill me
here nice la Ronn fin I'll hold him here
blue dive ah Oh get out um there was
something else wasn't there okay bye
babies now ladies I'll see you soon ah
no ah
Oh Oh aah what am i doing I didn't even
get a key where am I going what am i
doing I have a knife I'll play to the
victim that's right in an empty glass
container so I need container for the
oil in the machine room that's right
that's right that's right that's right
the oil in the machine room that I can
lube up this machine rooms over here I
can move it up where was it right there
[Music]
how's them right
yeah yeah he's there for to tell but I
think he's there I think the machine
rooms down that way
ah come on I'll go around ah no go away
oh wait no other machine rooms over here
wasn't it was it
I don't know going in circles I'm just
trying to get away from that guy
oh that is soothing music okay not that
one I think it's probably like the last
door or something no god damn it where
is it ah I'm back at the freaking
beginning you're kidding me right
okay this is Scott it's then if it's the
beginning it's up this hall and I could
keep going I'll find it yeah my weight
hanging bodies
[Music]
this way here it is that's right okay so
I need some oil have a jar isn't there
some place where I can get oil wasn't
that something need to find some oil
there was a note I had she no leaking
oil some of the pipes broken the key
under the oil leak
what ok ok ok if I need to put a jar
under the oil leak which I'm assuming is
five-guy is what I said where's its oil
leak
alright it's got to be around here right
cuz this is I got the note in here
nope oh wait a minute crap I don't have
that ironpython
yeah
okay got the rest of that oil didn't
quite fill me out but whatever uh oh
here we go
ah yeah level starts oil flow machine
must be running before the oil will
start flowing to start just pull the
gear in place pull the gear ah here we
go
engaged clear clunk ah there's the oil
leak got it nailed it bingo
I'm the best at this game now don't ask
me where that thing with the lever is
because I don't even know not a clue
I am all turned around in this place
like everything is just fast backwards
you heard me bass ackwards no I was
right here maybe was over here
nope die I was over here wasn't it yeah
here it is got it
oil on them dang it and it's quiggily
dude
here's where the cotton candy came from
oh don't be like that
oh come on I'm in LA it's gonna be a
[ __ ]
whoo no jars of colored chemicals aah
this all looks fun seriously what's with
the conch Eddie
ha ah iron plug 3 that's that's all I
needed
wasn't it whoo that's but I got the
blade of the victim I need other things
right Oh either way progress there were
other doors around here that I didn't
open are they like Easter eggs or do I
need to get find another key to get to
them I have a feeling that I and I need
to find another key but either way I can
get past the electro waves now I think
anyway
[Music]
I'm on okay okay I'm out I've got
everything I need
surprisingly I don't know if you guys
know if there's something else in here
that I need write in the comment section
below and let me know so that I can come
back before it gets too late and I get
too far ahead of myself because we're
running out of time for this episode so
there might be time to interject a gift
No
[Music]
[Applause]
haha something changed oh come on okay
I'm guessing that that might have been
it and I can just get us
okay I got the plug I can get in there
and I can move forward which is good I'm
trapped and I need to find three goons
Oh yuck Oh yuck because after this like
I could have chosen to go to the house
first I think but either way I got the
sacrificial blade for the victim you
know there's three guys in that big
central chamber in the lab so as soon as
I go there oh sorry about that
it's just this area once this area's
down I get out here at better don't
waste that ow
my eyeballs my regular balls no way it
was in here right this is it
nope I was a lie I thought that was a
portal room hey where is a portal I know
it's before those things
ize is it hello as some people went now
should name them Bob and Wade budget
douches no good liver Lily living lion
Fast Pass and then the ding dong ding
dong ding ok actually I don't know if
something important is gonna happen or
if like I because I only got 30 seconds
left and I don't know danger if electro
wave is on don't enter it can cause
death ok um by the way um if you're
watching this right now please go look
at I posted a link on the forums and I
posed a link through Twitter it's Fire
UK got a new series with me in it doing
hardcore survival my minecraft over on
fire UK they're a big minecraft
time-lapse thing and they're branching
out into different stuff so go see the
video there's a link on Facebook on
Twitter you can find it I'm in it cheer
me on because if you die you're out of
the game if I die I'm done forever so
please watch it and let me know what I'm
doing so and I'm all out of time so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
part
bye bye